willkommen zurück bei "Understanding Quantum Information and Computation", mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin der technische Direktor für Bildung
bei IBM Quantum. Dies ist die neunte Lektion der Reihe und die erste Lektion in der dritten Einheit, die sich mit der allgemeinen
Formulierung von Quanteninformation befasst. Bis jetzt haben wir die vereinfachte Formulierung der
Quanteninformation verwendet, bei der Quantenzustände durch komplexe Vektoren mit euklidischer Norm gleich
eins dargestellt werden. Im Gegensatz dazu werden in der allgemeinen Formulierung der Quanteninformation Quantenzustände durch
Matrizen eines bestimmten Typs dargestellt, die als Dichtematrizen bekannt sind. Diese erste Lektion der Einheit konzentriert sich speziell auf Dichtematrizen
und wir werden erfahren, was sie sind und wie sie funktionieren, während die Lektion fortschreitet. Dichtematrizen sind äußerst
nützlich und bieten verschiedene Vorteile, die wir besprechen werden. Sie ermöglichen es uns, eine
breitere Klasse von Zuständen darzustellen, als es Quantenzustandsvektoren können, einschließlich Zustände von Systemen, die beispielsweise durch Rauschen beeinflusst wurden, sowie zufälliger
Auswahlen von Quantenzuständen. Wir werden uns auch die Bloch-Sphäre ansehen, die uns eine sehr schöne
und einfache geometrische Denkweise über qubit-Zustände bietet, und wir werden sehen, wie sie sich mit Dichtematrizen auf eine
ziemlich bemerkenswerte Weise durch die Pauli-Matrizen verbindet. Schließlich werden wir Dichtematrizen im Kontext mehrerer
Systeme besprechen, und insbesondere werden wir sehen, wie sie es uns ermöglichen, Quantenzustände von isoliert betrachteten Systemen zu beschreiben, selbst wenn
sie mit anderen Systemen korreliert sind, einschließlich der Möglichkeit, dass sie mit anderen Systemen verschränkt sind. Das ist etwas Wichtiges, das man
tun können muss, und es lässt sich in der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanteninformation nicht leicht bewerkstelligen. Hier ist ein Überblick über die
Lektion: Wir beginnen mit den Grundlagen der Dichtematrizen, einschließlich relevanter Definitionen und einiger Beispiele, und wir werden
auch besprechen, wie sie mit Quantenzustandsvektoren zusammenhängen. Dann werden wir über konvexe Kombinationen von Dichtematrizen sprechen, oder anders
gesagt, was passiert, wenn wir gewichtete Mittelwerte von Dichtematrizen nehmen. Wir beginnen mit einem spezifischen
Beispiel des sogenannten vollständig gemischten Zustands. Wir werden sehen, wie klassische probabilistische Zustände als
Spezialfälle von Dichtematrizen betrachtet werden können, und wir werden besprechen, wie der Spektralsatz aus der linearen Algebra in
diesem Kontext ins Spiel kommt. Der dritte Teil der Lektion befasst sich mit der Bloch-Sphäre, die eine geometrische Sichtweise auf Zustände von
einzelnen qubits bietet, wie ich am Anfang der Lektion erwähnt habe. Im vierten Teil der Lektion werden wir besprechen, wie Dichtematrizen für mehrere
Systeme funktionieren. Wir werden Produktzustände und korrelierte Zustände verschiedener Art besprechen, einschließlich verschränkter Zustände, sowie
den Begriff eines reduzierten Zustands, der eine Dichtematrix-Beschreibung des Zustands eines isolierten Teils eines zusammengesetzten Systems ist
und der mithilfe einer Operation berechnet werden kann, die als partielle Spur bekannt ist. Bevor wir zum technischen Inhalt der Lektion selbst kommen, ist es
angebracht, einen kurzen Moment innezuhalten, um die Verwendung von Dichtematrizen zu motivieren. Mit der vereinfachten
Formulierung der Quanteninformation, die keine Dichtematrizen beinhaltet, können wir Quantenalgorithmen wie
den Shor-Faktorisierungsalgorithmus zum Beispiel ohne Schwierigkeiten beschreiben. Warum sollten wir uns also mit Dichtematrizen
oder dieser allgemeinen Formulierung der Quanteninformation überhaupt befassen? Nun, es gibt mehrere Gründe. Zum einen stellen Dichtematrizen
eine breitere Klasse von Quantenzuständen dar als Quantenzustandsvektoren, einschließlich Quantenzuständen, bei denen wir Unsicherheit oder
Zufälligkeit haben. Das ist wichtig, wenn wir die Auswirkungen von Rauschen auf Quantenberechnungen modellieren wollen, zum
Beispiel. Zweitens können wir mithilfe von Dichtematrizen Quantenzustände isolierter Teile zusammengesetzter Systeme beschreiben,
wie zum Beispiel Zustände von Systemen, die mit anderen Systemen verschränkt sind, die wir vielleicht vorübergehend ignorieren möchten, wie ich am Anfang der
Lektion erwähnt habe. Das lässt sich in der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanten-
information nicht leicht oder natürlich bewerkstelligen. Ein dritter Grund ist, dass klassische Information bei Verwendung von Dichtematrizen tatsächlich als
Spezialfall entsteht. Anstatt also eine im Wesentlichen analoge Beziehung zwischen probabilistischen Zuständen und Operationen auf
der einen Seite und Quantenzustandsvektoren und unitären Operationen auf der anderen Seite zu haben, werden Quanten- und klassische Information
gemeinsam innerhalb eines einzigen mathematischen Rahmens beschrieben, was für das mathematische Studium der
Quanteninformation nahezu unerlässlich ist. Wenn du also die Quanteninformation ernsthaft auf mathematischer Ebene verstehen möchtest, ist es sehr
empfehlenswert, dich mit Dichtematrizen zu befassen. Beginnen wir mit der Definition von Dichte-
matrizen. Nehmen wir für die Definition an, dass X ein System ist und Sigma seine klassische Zustandsmenge ist, und erinnere dich daran, dass
unsere Annahme bei Verwendung dieser Terminologie ist, dass Sigma endlich und nicht leer ist, und wie immer könnten wir
auch andere Namen wählen. Eine Dichtematrix, die einen Zustand des Systems X beschreibt, ist eine Matrix mit komplexen
Zahleneinträgen, deren Zeilen und Spalten in Entsprechung mit seiner klassischen Zustandsmenge gebracht wurden, und um das klarzustellen:
Die Entsprechung gilt für die Zeilen und Spalten gleichzeitig. Das bedeutet, dass Dichte-
matrizen immer quadratische Matrizen sind, und neben der Quadratigkeit müssen einige Bedingungen erfüllt sein,
auf die wir gleich eingehen werden. Für Dichtematrizen werden üblicherweise bestimmte griechische Kleinbuchstaben verwendet.
Rho ist oft die erste Wahl, und andere gängige Optionen sind das kleine Sigma und Tau, die auf dem
Bildschirm zu sehen sind. Das ist nur eine Konvention, aber wie üblich sind solche Konventionen hilfreich, weil sie Dinge
leichter erkennbar machen. Und jetzt sprechen wir über die Bedingungen oder Anforderungen, die Dichtematrizen erfüllen müssen, um
gültige Dichtematrizen zu sein. Es gibt zwei davon, und ich werde sie zunächst auflisten
und dann ausführlicher besprechen, was sie bedeuten. Die erste Bedingung ist, dass Dichte-
matrizen eine Einheitsspur haben müssen, oder anders gesagt, Spur gleich eins, und die zweite Bedingung ist, dass
Dichtematrizen positiv semidefinit sein müssen. In beiden Fällen haben wir prägnante symbolische Ausdrucksweisen für
diese zwei Bedingungen, die jetzt auf dem Bildschirm erscheinen. Lass mich die beiden Bedingungen ausführlicher besprechen.
Die erste Bedingung bezieht sich auf die Spur, die eine sehr wichtige Funktion ist, die für alle quadratischen Matrizen definiert ist
und einfach die Summe der Diagonaleinträge ist. Hier ist eine Gleichung, die das
explizit ausdrückt. Über die Spur lässt sich sehr viel sagen und warum sie wichtig ist, aber lass uns zunächst nur
eine sehr grundlegende Eigenschaft davon beobachten, nämlich dass sie eine lineare Funktion ist. Andere Eigenschaften der Spur werden auftauchen und wir werden sie besprechen, wenn
sie benötigt werden. Aber um unseren Fokus auf Dichtematrizen beizubehalten, gehen wir zur zweiten Anforderung über, und diese Anforderung ist, dass
Dichtematrizen positiv semidefinit sind. Das ist ebenfalls ein wichtiges Konzept, das in vielen Bereichen auftritt in
Physik, Chemie, Optimierung, maschinelles Lernen und andere Fachgebiete, und es lässt sich auf mehrere verschiedene, aber
äquivalente Weisen ausdrücken. Eine Möglichkeit ist zu sagen, dass eine Matrixzeile positiv semidefinit ist, wenn eine Matrix M existiert,
sodass rho gleich M Dagger mal M ist, und es stellt sich heraus, dass es keine Rolle spielt, ob wir verlangen, dass M selbst eine
quadratische Matrix ist, oder ob wir diese Einschränkung fallen lassen. Eine andere Möglichkeit, den Begriff der positiven
Semidefinitheit einer Matrixzeile zu beschreiben, ist zu sagen, dass rho hermitesch ist, was bedeutet, dass sie gleich ihrer eigenen konjugierten Transponierten ist, und alle
ihre Eigenwerte nicht-negative reelle Zahlen sind. Im Allgemeinen können hermitesche Matrizen
nur reelle Eigenwerte haben, aber diese können negativ sein. Wenn wir jedoch die zusätzliche Einschränkung hinzufügen, dass keiner der
Eigenwerte negativ sein darf, erhalten wir die positiv semidefiniten Matrizen. Übrigens: Wenn du eine
Matrix hast und wissen möchtest, ob sie positiv semidefinit ist, kannst du das anhand dieser Charakterisierung bestimmen. Es ist recht einfach zu
prüfen, ob eine Matrix hermitesch ist – das lässt sich oft auf den ersten Blick erkennen. Schwieriger ist es, die
Eigenwerte zu berechnen, aber das ist mit einem Computer nicht allzu schwierig, da es sehr effiziente Algorithmen dafür gibt.
Die letzte Charakterisierung, die ich erwähnen möchte – obwohl es noch weitere gibt –, ist, dass für jeden Spaltenvektor s, dessen
Anzahl an Einträgen mit der Anzahl der Zeilen und Spalten von rho übereinstimmt, die auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigte Ungleichung gilt. In Worten: s Dagger mal rho mal s muss eine nicht-negative reelle
Zahl sein. Es ist übrigens nicht offensichtlich, dass diese Charakterisierungen alle äquivalent sind, aber das sind sie. Ich möchte ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen, dass die
Notation, die wir üblicherweise verwenden, um anzuzeigen, dass eine Matrix rho positiv semidefinit ist, so aussieht, dass rho größer
oder gleich null ist. Das ist jedoch nur eine Kurzschreibweise und bedeutet nicht wörtlich, dass rho größer als
oder gleich null ist. rho ist eine Matrix, das würde keinen Sinn ergeben. Es bedeutet auch nicht,
dass jeder Eintrag von rho größer oder gleich null ist. Insbesondere gibt es positiv
semidefinite Matrizen, deren Einträge nicht alle nicht-negativ sind, und es gibt Matrizen, deren Einträge alle nicht-
negativ sind, die aber nicht positiv semidefinit sind. Die Idee hinter der Notation ist, dass positiv semidefinite
Matrizen wie Matrix-Analoga von nicht-negativen reellen Zahlen sind. Aber das ist nur eine Notation, und was sie bedeutet, ist
genau das, was wir bereits besprochen haben. Schauen wir uns nun einige Beispiele an, beginnend mit einem Beispiel einer
positiv semidefiniten Matrix. Tatsächlich ist es ganz einfach, ein Beispiel einer
positiv semidefiniten Matrix zufällig zu erzeugen, indem man einfach eine Matrix M beliebig wählt und dann M Dagger mal
M berechnet. Hier ist zum Beispiel eine Matrix M, die nicht besonders speziell ist. Ich habe
diese Matrix zufällig generiert, indem ich Real- und Imaginärteile der Einträge unabhängig voneinander als ganze Zahlen zwischen minus 9 und plus
9 gewählt habe. Muster oder Strukturen sind hier also rein zufällig. Durch Multiplikation der
konjugierten Transponierten von M mit M erhalten wir diese Matrix hier, die daher positiv
semidefinit ist. Natürlich ist die Erkenntnis, die wir aus einem zufälligen Beispiel gewinnen können, begrenzt, aber es zeigt einige
Eigenschaften, die positiv semidefiniten Matrizen im Allgemeinen gemeinsam sind. Insbesondere wirst du feststellen,
dass die Diagonaleinträge – also die entlang der Linie von oben links nach unten rechts – alle nicht-negative reelle
Zahlen sind. Außerdem sind die Nebendiagonaleinträge nicht allzu groß im Vergleich zu den entsprechenden Diagonal-
einträgen, also dem in derselben Zeile und dem in derselben Spalte wie der jeweilige Nebendiagonaleintrag, den wir betrachten.
Die Geschichte ist jedoch komplexer, und es ist wichtig zu erkennen, dass positiv semidefinit eine
Eigenschaft einer Matrix als Ganzes ist und nicht nur eine Bedingung an einzelne Einträge. Das war also ein Beispiel einer
positiv semidefiniten Matrix, und du kannst sehr einfach weitere Beispiele durch eine ähnliche
Methodik erzeugen. Schauen wir uns nun einige Beispiele von Dichtematrizen an, bei denen zusätzlich zur positiven Semidefinitheitsbedingung auch die Spur
gleich eins ist. Hier sind einige Beispiele von 2x2-Dichtematrizen. Die Spur ist in
allen vier Fällen gleich eins, und wir können auch sehen, dass diese hermitesche Matrizen sind. Mit der zweiten Charakterisierung von
positiv semidefiniten Matrizen von vorhin bleibt nur noch zu prüfen, ob die Eigenwerte alle nicht-negativ sind.
Das überlasse ich dir zum Nachprüfen, falls du möchtest. Bei 2x2-Matrizen ist es nicht allzu schwer, Eigenwerte von Hand zu berechnen.
Du kannst aber auch einfach einen Computer fragen. Du kannst zum Beispiel die Funktion eig in der linearen Algebra-
Bibliothek für Python verwenden. Wir können eine Dichtematrix auch erhalten, indem wir einfach eine beliebige von-null-verschiedene
positiv semidefinite Matrix durch ihre Spur dividieren. Hier ist zum Beispiel die Dichtematrix, die wir erhalten, wenn wir
das Beispiel von vor wenigen Momenten durch seine Spur dividieren. Division durch die Spur auf diese Weise
erhält stets die positiv semidefinite Eigenschaft, und wir erhalten sicher eine Matrix mit Spur gleich eins, da
die Spur eine lineare Funktion ist. Das ist nur eine kleine Sammlung von Beispielen, und wir werden mehr sehen, wenn die
Lektion fortgesetzt wird. Als Nächstes nehmen wir uns kurz Zeit, um die Interpretation oder
die intuitive Bedeutung von Dichtematrizen zu besprechen. Das Erste, was ich ansprechen möchte, ist, dass es etwas ungewöhnlich erscheinen mag,
den Zustand eines Systems mit einer Matrix statt mit einem Vektor darzustellen. Im Gegensatz dazu verwenden wir in der vereinfachten
Formulierung der Quanteninformation Vektoren zur Darstellung von Zuständen, während Matrizen – insbesondere unitäre Matrizen –
Aktionen oder Operationen darstellen. So funktioniert nun einmal die Mathematik, und obwohl man
Matrizen immer als lineare Abbildungen betrachten kann, assoziieren wir mit der linearen Abbildung, die einer gegebenen Dichtematrix entspricht, typischerweise keine direkte intuitive
Bedeutung. Dennoch ist die Tatsache, dass Dichtematrizen tatsächlich Matrizen sind, ein entscheidend wichtiger Aspekt von ihnen, wie wir
noch sehen werden, wenn wir weitermachen. Um aber kurz nur ein Beispiel zu nennen: Die Eigenwerte einer gegebenen Dichtematrix
erweisen sich als sehr wichtig, weil sie beschreiben, wie viel Zufälligkeit oder Ungewissheit dem Zustand innewohnt,
den diese Dichtematrix beschreibt. Eine andere Möglichkeit, über Dichtematrizen auf intuitiver Ebene nachzudenken,
konzentriert sich auf die Einträge dieser Matrizen. Erinnere dich daran, dass die Zeilen und Spalten von Dichtematrizen den
klassischen Zuständen des jeweiligen Systems entsprechen, über das wir sprechen. Für jeden Eintrag haben wir also einen
klassischen Zustand, der der Zeile dieses Eintrags entspricht, und einen klassischen Zustand, der der Spalte dieses Eintrags entspricht,
für den klassischen Zustand, der der Zeile dieses Eintrags entspricht, und einen klassischen Zustand, der der Spalte dieses Eintrags entspricht.
Einträge für die diagonalen Einträge sind diese beiden klassischen Zustände derselbe Zustand, und deshalb sind die diagonalen Einträge
besonders, und eine Möglichkeit, die diagonalen Einträge zu interpretieren, ist, dass es sich um Wahrscheinlichkeiten handelt, und zwar genauer gesagt sind es
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, dass der entsprechende klassische Zustand auftreten würde, wenn wir eine Standardbasismessung durchführen würden
an dem System, dessen Quantenzustand wir beschreiben. Für die nicht-diagonalen Einträge hingegen haben wir einen klassischen Zustand, der der Zeile
dieses Eintrags entspricht, und einen anderen klassischen Zustand, der der Spalte dieses Eintrags entspricht, und sehr informell gesprochen
beschreiben diese Einträge den Grad, in dem sich diese beiden klassischen Zustände in Quantensuperposition befinden, sowie die
relative Phase zwischen ihnen, was möglicherweise klarer wird, wenn die Lektion fortschreitet und wir uns mehr
bestimmte Beispiele genauer ansehen. Die Details sind an diesem Punkt vielleicht nicht klar, aber lass dich davon bitte nicht stören –
das ist sehr informell und soll nur eine intuitive Idee sein, die du im Hinterkopf behalten kannst.
Als Nächstes schauen wir uns den Zusammenhang zwischen Dichtematrizen und Quantenzustandsvektoren an, die Spaltenvektoren sind,
deren euklidische Norm gleich eins ist. Zur Erinnerung an die mathematische Definition: Angenommen, wir haben einen
Quantenzustandsvektor Ψ, der den Zustand eines bestimmten Systems darstellt, ist die Dichtematrix, die denselben
Quantenzustand darstellt, durch Ket-Ψ mal Bra-Ψ gegeben, wie hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Um das klarzustellen: Die Indizes von Ψ
entsprechen auf irgendeine Weise den klassischen Zuständen des jeweiligen Systems, und das ist genau dieselbe Entsprechung, die wir zwischen
den Zeilen und Spalten unserer Dichtematrix und den klassischen Zuständen des Systems haben. Wenn wir uns vorstellen, dass es n
klassische Zustände des Systems gibt, und wir Spalten- und Zeilenvektoren als Matrizen betrachten, dann ist Ket-Ψ eine n-mal-1-Matrix
und Bra-Ψ ist eine 1-mal-n-Matrix, sodass wir bei der Multiplikation eine n-mal-n
Matrix erhalten. Diese ist aufgrund ihrer Form immer eine positiv semidefinite Matrix, und sie hat außerdem eine Spur gleich
eins, da Ψ ein Einheitsvektor ist, und das werden wir uns bald
genauer ansehen. Quantenzustände, die durch Dichtematrizen dieser Form dargestellt werden, heißen reine
Zustände. Hier sind einige Beispiele. Betrachten wir zunächst diesen Zustand
hier, der einer Art Plus-Zustand ähnelt, außer dass der Eintrag, der dem klassischen Zustand eins entspricht,
imaginär ist. Wenn wir die konjugiert Transponierte berechnen, erhalten wir ein Minuszeichen, weil das komplexe Konjugat von i
minus i ist, und wenn wir die Multiplikation durchführen, erhalten wir die Matrix, die hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Sie ist hermitesch, wie wir
sofort sehen können, und hat zufällig einen Eigenwert gleich eins und einen Eigenwert gleich
null, ist also positiv semidefinit, und ihre Spur ist gleich eins, sie ist also eine Dichtematrix, wie
erwartet. Wir können die Dichtematrizen entsprechend der Standardbasis und der Plus-Minus-Basis auf ähnliche Weise berechnen, und diese Dichtematrizen
sind hier gezeigt. Und hier ist noch ein weiteres Beispiel eines Quantenzustandsvektors, das
weit am Anfang der ersten Lektion der Reihe erschienen ist. Wenn wir die konjugiert Transponierte berechnen und dann multiplizieren,
erhalten wir die Dichtematrix, die hier gezeigt ist. Auch sie ist hermitesch und hat eine
Spur gleich eins, und wenn du die Eigenwerte berechnest, wirst du feststellen, dass sie ebenfalls einen Eigenwert gleich eins und einen
Eigenwert gleich null hat. Übrigens ist das ein gemeinsames Merkmal aller reinen Zustände: Sie haben immer einen Eigenwert
gleich eins, und die übrigen Eigenwerte sind alle null. Im Allgemeinen gilt für einen völlig beliebigen Quantenzustandsvektor
Ψ mit einer beliebigen Anzahl von Einträgen: wenn wir Ket-Ψ mit Bra-Ψ multiplizieren, erhalten wir eine
Dichtematrix, die so aussieht. Beachte insbesondere, dass die diagonalen Einträge immer eines der
Einträge von Ψ multipliziert mit seinem eigenen komplexen Konjugat sind, was wir alternativ als den Betrag zum Quadrat dieses Eintrags ausdrücken können, und das ist
eine Möglichkeit zu sehen, dass die Spur immer gleich eins ist. Es stimmt auch mit der Anmerkung überein, die ich früher in der Lektion gemacht habe, über die
diagonalen Einträge einer Dichtematrix, die uns sagen, wie groß die Wahrscheinlichkeiten wären, jeden möglichen klassischen Zustand zu sehen,
wenn wir eine Standardbasismessung durchführen würden. Und eine letzte Anmerkung:
Es gibt kein Problem bezüglich globaler Phasen bei Dichtematrizen. Zwei Quantenzustände sind genau dann identisch, wenn ihre Dichte-
matrizen gleich sind. Angenommen insbesondere, wir haben zwei Quantenzustandsvektoren Ψ und φ, die
bis auf eine globale Phase äquivalent sind, was bedeutet, dass wir einen von ihnen – φ, sagen wir – als den anderen mal
einer komplexen Zahl auf dem Einheitskreis ausdrücken können. Wenn wir die Dichtematrixdarstellung von φ berechnen, werden wir
feststellen, dass der globale Phasenfaktor mit seinem eigenen komplexen Konjugat multipliziert wird, was uns eins ergibt, sodass er
effektiv verschwindet und wir genau dieselbe Dichtematrix erhalten, die wir aus Ψ bekommen. Das ist gewissermaßen ein
netter kleiner Bonus. Und allgemeiner gibt es überhaupt kein Problem bezüglich Äquivalenz bis auf globale Phasen, wenn wir
mit Dichtematrizen arbeiten. Das ist im Grunde nur eine Degeneriertheit, die entsteht, wenn wir Quantenzustandsvektoren anstatt
Dichtematrizen verwenden, um Quantenzustände darzustellen. Dichtematrizen besitzen eine wichtige Eigenschaft, nämlich dass konvexe
Kombinationen von Dichtematrizen probabilistische oder zufällige Auswahlen von Quanten-
zuständen darstellen. Eine andere Art, das zu sagen, ist, dass Dichtematrizen auf sinnvolle Weise gemittelt werden können, was
bei Quantenzustandsvektoren nicht möglich ist. Um das genauer zu erklären, beginnen wir mit der Situation, in der
wir zwei Dichtematrizen ρ und σ haben, die Quantenzustände eines Systems darstellen. Stellen wir uns vor, dass das
System mit Wahrscheinlichkeit p im Zustand ρ präpariert wird, für eine Wahl von p zwischen null und eins, und ansonsten das
System im Zustand σ präpariert wird. Wenn beispielsweise p gleich 1/2 ist,
könnten wir uns vorstellen, dass jemand eine faire Münze wirft, und wenn Kopf fällt, führt die Person einen Prozess durch, der das System in
den Zustand ρ versetzt, und ansonsten, wenn Zahl fällt, führt die Person einen anderen Prozess durch, der das System in den
Zustand σ versetzt. Die Frage ist nun: Was ist der Zustand des Systems? Und um das klarzustellen:
Wir interessieren uns für den Zustand des Systems für sich allein, ohne andere Informationen zu berücksichtigen, die möglicherweise darüber vorhanden sind,
welche Präparation durchgeführt wurde. Stellen wir uns zum Beispiel vor, dass wir keinen Zugang zur Münze oder zur
Erinnerung desjenigen haben, der die Zustandspräparation durchgeführt hat. Die Antwort auf diese Frage ist, dass es einfach der gewichtete Durchschnitt der beiden Dichte-
matrizen ist: p mal ρ plus (1 minus p) mal σ. Das ist übrigens vollständig
analog zu dem, was wir hätten, wenn ρ und σ keine Dichtematrizen, sondern Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren wären.
die probabilistische Zustände darstellen – das ist also nichts Schockierendes oder Mysteriöses, sondern eher etwas,
das vielleicht aus der Wahrscheinlichkeitstheorie bekannt ist. Wir machen diese Art von Mittelwertbildung ständig, wenn wir Wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnen und darüber nachdenken,
wie klassische Zufallsauswahlen funktionieren. Und der Punkt ist, dass das auch für Dichtematrizen funktioniert – aber beachte, dass es
nicht für Quanten-Zustandsvektoren gilt. Das heißt, du kannst im Allgemeinen nicht einfach zwei Quanten-Zustandsvektoren
so mitteln und hoffen, einen gültigen Quanten-Zustandsvektor zu erhalten. Wenn du es versuchst, bekommst du meistens einen Vektor, der
keine euklidische Norm gleich eins hat. Bei Dichtematrizen hingegen werden gewichtete Mittelwerte wie dieser immer
gültige Dichtematrizen sein, und was noch wichtiger ist: Die Dichtematrix, die du erhältst, repräsentiert diese zufällige Auswahl
auf sinnvolle Weise. Das lässt sich auf Zufallsauswahlen verallgemeinern, bei denen es mehr als zwei
Alternativen gibt. Insbesondere wenn wir M mögliche Dichtematrizen und einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor mit M Einträgen haben – einen
für jede Dichtematrix – und ein System mit der entsprechenden Wahrscheinlichkeit in jedem möglichen Zustand präpariert wird,
dann beschreibt der gewichtete Durchschnitt dieser Dichtematrizen den resultierenden Zustand des Systems. Und übrigens, wenn
wir von einer konvexen Kombination von Dichtematrizen sprechen, meinen wir genau das: Eine konvexe Kombination ist einfach eine lineare
Kombination, bei der die Koeffizienten einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor bilden. Das wird immer eine Dichte-
matrix sein, und eine einfache und prägnante Formulierung davon in mathematischen Begriffen ist, dass die Menge aller Dichtematrizen,
die einem gegebenen System entsprechen, eine konvexe Menge ist. Wenn wir also etwa M Quanten-Zustandsvektoren
s 0 bis s M minus eins haben, zusammen mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten p 0 bis p m minus eins, die zusammen einen
Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor bilden, und ein System wird mit Wahrscheinlichkeit PK im Zustand s k präpariert für jedes k, dann ist der
resultierende Zustand des Systems durch die Dichtematrix beschrieben, die hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Insbesondere mitteln wir nicht
die Quanten-Zustandsvektoren selbst, sondern wir mitteln die entsprechenden Dichte-
matrizen. Im Allgemeinen wird ein solcher Zustand keine Darstellung als einzelner Quanten-Zustandsvektor haben,
es sei denn, es passiert etwas Triviales – zum Beispiel, dass alle Quanten-Zustandsvektoren bis auf eine globale Phase äquivalent sind, oder alle bis auf einen der
Wahrscheinlichkeiten null sind. Wir werden aus einem solchen Prozess keinen reinen Quantenzustand erhalten, sondern das, was man
einen gemischten Quantenzustand nennt, bei dem eine inhärente Ungewissheit vorliegt. Schauen wir uns ein einfaches
Beispiel an. Angenommen, wir haben ein qubit, und mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 wird das qubit im Nullzustand präpariert, andernfalls
wird es im Plus-Zustand präpariert. Hier ist die Dichtematrix, die wir durch Mittelwertbildung erhalten, wie ich es
beschrieben habe. Wir berechnen die Dichtematrizen für die zwei möglichen Zustände, multiplizieren mit den entsprechenden Wahrscheinlichkeiten und addieren die
Ergebnisse. Was wir erhalten, ist tatsächlich eine Dichtematrix: sie ist hermitesch, ihre Spur ist gleich eins,
und wenn du die Eigenwerte dieser Matrix berechnest, erhältst du zwei positive reelle Zahlen – und zwar zwei Zahlen, die dir inzwischen wahrscheinlich vertraut sein sollten:
Kosinus-Quadrat von Pi über 8 und Sinus-Quadrat von Pi über 8, also ungefähr 0,85 und
0,15. Es gibt keine einzelne Quanten-Zustandsvektor-Darstellung des Zustands – es ist kein reiner Zustand. Als nächstes schauen wir uns einen
bestimmten Dichtzustand an, der einen Quantenzustand eines einzelnen qubit darstellt, bekannt als der vollständig gemischte
Zustand. Dieser Zustand tritt häufig auf, daher ist es gut, einen Namen dafür zu haben. Es ist auch ein gutes Beispiel, weil er
eine wichtige Eigenschaft von Dichtematrizen veranschaulicht. Es gibt tatsächlich einen analog definierten vollständig gemischten Zustand für jedes
System, aber für jetzt konzentrieren wir uns auf diesen Zustand für ein einzelnes qubit, um die Dinge
einfach zu halten. Angenommen, wir setzen den Zustand eines qubit zufällig entweder auf den Nullzustand oder den Einszustand, jeweils mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 – ähnlich wie ein gleichmäßig zufälliges Bit. Wir können die Dichtematrix-Darstellung dieses
Zustands auf die übliche Weise berechnen: Wir nehmen den Durchschnitt der zwei Dichtematrix-Darstellungen der Zustände. So sieht das
in Matrixform aus, und was wir erhalten, ist die Identitätsmatrix geteilt durch
zwei. Dieser Zustand ist bekannt als der vollständig gemischte Zustand, und er repräsentiert im Grunde vollständige oder maximale
Ungewissheit über ein qubit – genau wie ein gleichmäßiger Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor maximale Ungewissheit in der
klassischen probabilistischen Situation darstellt. Im Allgemeinen ist für ein beliebiges System der vollständig gemischte Zustand der
Zustand, den wir erhalten, wenn wir gleichmäßig einen Standardbasiszustand auswählen, und die Dichtematrix-Darstellung ist die
Identitätsmatrix geteilt durch die Dimension – oder gleichwertig die Anzahl der klassischen Zustände dieses
Systems. An diesem Punkt ist das nur Terminologie, aber wenn wir die Einrichtung ein wenig ändern, sehen wir eine wichtige Eigenschaft von
Dichtematrizen. Insbesondere nehmen wir an, wir ändern das Verfahren und
ersetzen die Standard-Basiszustände null und eins durch die Plus- und Minus-Zustände. Dieses Mal beginnen wir mit dem
Ausdruck, der auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird, aber wenn wir die Arithmetik durchführen, erhalten wir genau dieselbe
Dichtematrix. Es ist die Identitätsmatrix geteilt durch zwei – also derselbe Zustand wie zuvor: der
vollständig gemischte Zustand. Das ist, wie man sagt, ein Feature und kein Bug. Die zwei Verfahren sind tatsächlich
verschieden, aber wenn du nur das resultierende qubit hast, gibt es physikalisch keine Möglichkeit, sie zu unterscheiden –
nicht einmal im statistischen Sinne. Wenn du zum Beispiel eine Standardbasismessung an diesem qubit durchführst
nach dem ersten Verfahren, würdest du offensichtlich das Ergebnis null mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 und das Ergebnis eins mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 erhalten – aber du würdest auch
genau die gleichen Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten für das zweite Verfahren erhalten. Und das gilt für jeden anderen Test, den du dir
ausdenken könntest – vorausgesetzt, du testest nur das qubit selbst. Im Allgemeinen beschreiben Dichtematrizen nicht, wie ein System
präpariert wurde, sondern sagen dir nur, was passieren wird, wenn du mit diesem System etwas machst – ob das nun das Durchführen von
Operationen oder Messungen ist. Und tatsächlich sind Dichtematrizen in dieser Hinsicht perfekt:
Wenn zwei verschiedene Alternativen zur selben Dichtematrix führen, können sie nicht unterschieden werden – nicht einmal
im statistischen Sinne. Wenn aber die zwei Dichtematrizen verschieden sind, wird es eine Möglichkeit geben, sie zu unterscheiden – nicht
notwendigerweise eindeutig, aber im statistischen Sinne. Wenn wir die allgemeine Formulierung der Quanten-
information verwenden, taucht klassische Information im Wesentlichen als Sonderfall auf, und ich erkläre jetzt, wie das
funktioniert. Konkret werden wir sehen, wie probabilistische Zustände durch Dichte-
matrizen dargestellt werden können. Fangen wir mit klassischen Zuständen an, beginnend mit einem einfachen
Hier sind zum Beispiel die Dichtematrix-Darstellungen der Null- und Eins-Standardbasiszustände eines
qubit. Wir verknüpfen diese Zustände mit den klassischen Zuständen 0 und 1, und so können wir uns diese Dichtematrizen vorstellen als
Darstellungen dieser Zustände. Das ist sehr einfach, und wir können das leicht verallgemeinern.
Wenn wir ein System haben, dessen klassische Zustandsmenge Sigma ist, dann wird der klassische Zustand a dargestellt durch oder
ist verknüpft mit der Dichtematrix ket a bra a. Diese Matrix hat eine einzige Eins in dem
Diagonaleintrag, dessen Zeile und Spalte dem klassischen Zustand a entspricht, und jeder andere Eintrag ist
null. Probabilistische Zustände werden durch konvexe Kombinationen von Matrizen dieser Form dargestellt, was naheliegend ist,
angesichts dessen, was wir über Dichtematrizen wissen und wie sie funktionieren – insbesondere dass konvexe Kombinationen von Dichtematrizen zufällige oder
probabilistische Auswahlen von Quantenzuständen darstellen. Nehmen wir zum Beispiel an, dass wir
ein System X haben, dessen klassische Zustandsmenge die ganzen Zahlen 0 bis n minus eins enthält, für eine positive ganze Zahl n.
Natürlich geht dabei kaum oder gar keine Allgemeinheit verloren, wenn wir annehmen, dass unsere klassische Zustandsmenge diese Form hat. Hätten wir eine
andere klassische Zustandsmenge, könnten wir die klassischen Zustände einfach auf diese Weise umbenennen, und es ist oft recht praktisch, die Annahme zu treffen, dass unsere
klassischen Zustandsmengen so aussehen – vor allem, weil das es leichter macht, Dinge explizit in Form von
Vektoren und Matrizen zu schreiben. Angenommen, wir haben einen probabilistischen Zustand des Systems X,
dargestellt durch einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor auf die übliche Weise. Wir können diesen probabilistischen Zustand mit einer Dichte-
matrix verknüpfen, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Wir nehmen den gewichteten Durchschnitt der Dichtematrizen, die den
verschiedenen klassischen Zuständen entsprechen, und was wir erhalten, ist eine diagonale Dichtematrix. Insbesondere sehen wir die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
auf der Diagonale dieser Matrix, und jeder andere Eintrag ist gleich null. Natürlich ist das eine Dichtematrix –
das erwarten wir, aber wir können es auch direkt begründen: Es ist eine hermitesche Matrix, ihre Spur
ist gleich eins, weil sich die Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu eins summieren, und im Fall einer Diagonalmatrix sind die Eigenwerte die Diagonal-
einträge, und sie sind alle nicht-negativ, weil es Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind. Beachte auch, dass jede
diagonale Dichtematrix – also eine, deren Nebendiagonaleinträge alle null sind – so aussehen muss. Kurz gesagt:
Probabilistische Zustände können mit diagonalen Dichtematrizen verknüpft werden. Beachte übrigens, dass dies mit der
informellen Interpretation der Einträge von Dichtematrizen übereinstimmt, die ich am Anfang der Lektion erwähnt habe. Insbesondere befindet sich hier nichts in
Quantenüberlagerung – es ist im Grunde nur klassische Zufälligkeit, und entsprechend sind alle Nebendiagonalen-
einträge null. Früher in dieser Reihe haben wir das Spektralsatz besprochen, und das haben wir
speziell für unitäre Matrizen im Kontext der Phasenschätzung getan. Der Spektralsatz ist jedoch
allgemeiner als das, d.h. er sagt uns etwas über eine breitere Klasse von Matrizen aus als nur unitäre
Matrizen, und insbesondere gilt er für eine Klasse von Matrizen, die man normale Matrizen nennt, welche alle Matrizen umfasst, die
sowie unitäre Matrizen. Was wir jetzt tun werden, ist eine andere Formulierung dieses Satzes zu betrachten, diesmal mit Fokus auf
positiv semidefinite Matrizen, und dann werden wir sehen, dass er uns etwas sehr Interessantes und grundlegend Wichtiges über Dichte-
matrizen verrät. Angenommen, p ist eine beliebige positiv semidefinite Matrix – das umfasst jede Dichtematrix sowie jede
positiv semidefinite Matrix, deren Spur nicht notwendigerweise gleich eins ist. p ist positiv semidefinit, also muss sie
quadratisch sein, d.h. N mal N für eine bestimmte Wahl von N, und wir werden diese Zahl n referenzieren müssen, also sei N
entsprechend gewählt. Oder anders ausgedrückt: Angenommen, p ist n mal n. Was der Satz uns in diesem Fall sagt, ist, dass
es eine Orthonormalbasis von Vektoren geben muss, die wir s0 bis sn minus eins nennen, zusammen mit nicht-negativen reellen
Zahlen Lambda 0 bis Lambda n minus eins, sodass P ausgedrückt werden kann wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt.
In Worten: Wenn wir jedes Lambda K mit ket sk mal bra sk multiplizieren und dann
über alle K von 0 bis n minus eins summieren, erhalten wir P. Dies nennt man eine Spektral-
zerlegung von P. Jedes Lambda K ist notwendigerweise ein Eigenwert von P, und jedes s ist ein normierter Eigenvektor von P,
der zu diesem Eigenwert gehört. Wenn du in Lektion 7 zur Phasenschätzung zurückschaust, findest du einen ähnlichen Satz
für unitäre Matrizen. Dort sind die Eigenwerte komplexe Zahlen auf dem Einheitskreis statt nicht-negativer reeller
Zahlen, aber ansonsten ist es dieselbe Idee, und das sind wirklich nur zwei Spezialfälle eines allgemeineren Satzes, bekannt als
der Spektralsatz. Er gilt nicht für jede Matrix – die Matrix muss mit ihrer
konjugiert transponierten Matrix vertauschen, und das bedeutet, dass eine Matrix normal ist. Aber das gilt tatsächlich immer
sowohl für unitäre Matrizen als auch für positiv semidefinite Matrizen und für hermitesche Matrizen allgemeiner, wo
wir immer reelle Eigenwerte haben, aber nicht notwendigerweise nicht-negative. Das ist also eine Aussage des
Spektralsatzes speziell für positiv semidefinite Matrizen, und jetzt schauen wir uns an, was er uns über Dichte-
matrizen sagt. Was er uns sagt, ist, dass wir für eine beliebige n mal n Dichtematrix diese Matrix immer als konvexe
Kombination von n reinen Zuständen ausdrücken können, und außerdem können wir diese n reinen Zustände als
orthogonal wählen. Das folgt ziemlich direkt aus dem Satz zusammen mit einer grundlegenden Tatsache aus der linearen Algebra, nämlich dass
die Summe der Eigenwerte jeder Matrix immer gleich der Spur dieser Matrix ist. Mit anderen Worten: Alles, was wir wirklich
tun, ist die Eigenwerte p 0 bis pN minus eins umzubenennen und dann zu beobachten, dass wenn wir das tun und
diese Eigenwerte in einen n-dimensionalen Vektor zusammenfassen, wir notwendigerweise einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor erhalten, weil sie alle nicht-negativ sein müssen und ihre Summe gleich
der Spur von rho ist, die eins ist, weil rho eine Dichtematrix ist. Das ist also recht einfach, aber es ist
konzeptionell wirklich grundlegend. Was es uns sagt, ist, dass jede Dichtematrix,
egal wie kompliziert sie erscheinen mag, dadurch entstehen könnte, dass man zunächst eine Orthonormalbasis des jeweiligen Systems
auswählt und dann zufällig einen Quantenzustand aus dieser Basis gemäß einer Wahl für die Wahr-
scheinlichkeiten auswählt. Wenn nicht sofort klar ist, warum das interessant oder wichtig ist, ist das in Ordnung, aber wir verwenden diese
Tatsache sehr häufig, wenn wir über Dichtematrizen nachdenken, und tatsächlich ist das Ausdrücken einer gegebenen Dichtematrix
auf diese Weise oft das Allererste, was wir tun, wenn wir sie
besser verstehen wollen. Hier ist ein Beispiel: Erinnere dich an die Dichtematrix, die wir zuvor erstellt haben, bei der wir zufällig zwischen
dem Nullzustand und dem Pluszustand, jeweils mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2, was, wie wir berechnet haben, eine Dichtematrix ergibt, die
so aussieht: Der Nullzustand und der Pluszustand sind nicht orthogonal, also ist das keine
Spektralzerlegung, aber wenn wir eine berechnen – was wir mit einem Computer oder in einem solchen Fall auch von Hand tun können – dann erhalten wir
diesen Ausdruck für unsere Dichtematrix, wobei die Eigenwerte diese Zahlen sind, die immer wieder auftauchen, und
die zugehörigen Eigenvektoren wie hier auf dem Bildschirm unten gezeigt gewählt werden können. Auch diese Vektoren haben wir schon gesehen, zum Beispiel im
Kontext des CHSH-Spiels in Lektion Vier. Das ist interessant: Gemäß
dem ursprünglichen Ausdruck erhalten wir diesen Zustand, indem wir gleichmäßig zwischen zwei Zuständen wählen – dem Nullzustand und
dem Pluszustand. Tatsächlich erhalten wir aber exakt dieselbe Dichtematrix, indem wir zufällig zwischen zwei reinen
Zuständen wählen, allerdings mit einer sehr starken Gewichtung zugunsten eines der beiden – etwa 85 % für den ersten und nur etwa 15 % für
den zweiten. In gewissem Sinne steckt also eigentlich weniger Zufälligkeit im Zustand, als es ursprünglich den Anschein haben
mochte. Es gibt eine sehr schöne geometrische Möglichkeit, Quantenzustände eines einzelnen qubit zu denken und zu visualisieren, bekannt
als die Bloch-Sphäre. Sie funktioniert nur für einzelne qubits; für Systeme mit drei
oder mehr klassischen Zuständen, einschließlich zwei oder mehr qubits zusammen, funktioniert sie nicht mehr. Sie ist also ziemlich eingeschränkt, aber
dennoch ist sie eine großartige Möglichkeit, über die Zustände eines einzelnen qubit nachzudenken. Sie hätte bereits
in Lektion Eins der Reihe über einzelne Systeme eingeführt werden können, ist aber nicht wirklich wesentlich für das Verständnis, wie Quanteninformation funktioniert, und sie hat auch eine
wirklich schöne Verbindung mit Dichtematrizen, sodass sie natürlich in diese Lektion passt. Und ich werde sie tatsächlich
auf eine etwas andere Weise erklären, als sie vielleicht am häufigsten erklärt wird, nämlich indem ich Dichtematrizen verwende, um sie effektiv
herzuleiten. Wenn du also bereits mit der Bloch-Sphäre vertraut bist, könnte diese Erklärung etwas anders sein als die Art,
wie du sie zuerst kennengelernt hast, aber am Ende sollte sie natürlich äquivalent sein. Wir beginnen damit, über
die möglichen reinen Zustände eines qubit nachzudenken, zunächst wie durch Quantenzustandsvektoren
dargestellt. Bis auf eine globale Phase kann jeder qubit-Quantenzustandsvektor ausgedrückt werden als
hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Genau gesagt haben wir zwei reelle Zahlen Theta und Phi, und wir stellen uns
diese zwei Zahlen als Winkel vor, ausgedrückt in Radiant. Die erste Zahl Theta liegt zwischen 0 und Pi, oder äquivalent ist es ein
Winkel zwischen 0 und 180°, und die zweite Zahl Phi liegt zwischen 0 und 2 Pi, einschließlich 0, aber nicht 2
Pi – also ist das ein beliebiger Winkel zwischen 0 und 360°. Der Nulleintrag unseres Vektors ist
Kosinus von Theta geteilt durch 2, also eine reelle Zahl zwischen 0 und 1, und insbesondere ist sie notwendigerweise nicht negativ.
Und der Einseintrag unseres Vektors ist e hoch i mal Phi mal Sinus von Theta geteilt durch 2, und das kann
eine beliebige komplexe Zahl auf oder innerhalb des komplexen Einheitskreises sein. Das ist immer ein Einheitsvektor, oder
anders gesagt, es ist ein gültiger Quantenzustandsvektor. Und für jeden gegebenen qubit-Quantenzustandsvektor können wir immer
einen Vektor dieser Form finden, der äquivalent zu diesem Vektor bis auf eine globale Phase ist. Insbesondere können wir immer
den gegebenen Vektor mit einer globalen Phase multiplizieren, um den Nulleintrag zu einer nicht negativen reellen Zahl zu machen, Theta so wählen,
dass dieser Eintrag passt, und dann Phi so wählen, dass er zum Einseintrag passt. Der Betrag des Einseintrags wird
immer notwendigerweise mit dem Sinus von Theta geteilt durch zwei übereinstimmen, unter der Annahme, dass wir mit einem Einheits-
vektor begonnen haben. Es ist nicht ganz so, dass Theta und Phi eindeutig durch den Quantenzustandsvektor bestimmt sind, mit dem wir begonnen haben,
aber fast. Es gibt immer einen eindeutigen Wert von Theta zwischen null und Pi, der funktioniert,
und normalerweise gibt es einen eindeutigen Wert von Phi, der funktioniert, aber in zwei Sonderfällen ist das nicht der Fall. Insbesondere wenn wir mit einem
Standardbasiszustand begonnen haben, dann wird Theta entweder null oder Pi sein, und in beiden Fällen spielt es keine Rolle, was Phi ist – es ist
völlig irrelevant. Wenn Theta null ist, ist der Kosinus von Theta geteilt durch 2 gleich 1, und der Sinus von Theta geteilt durch 2
ist null, also multiplizieren wir e hoch i mal Phi mit null, sodass es keinen Unterschied macht, was Phi ist.
Und wenn Theta Pi ist, dann ist dieses Mal der Kosinus null und der Sinus eins, also haben wir e hoch i mal Phi mal Ket-1, aber diese
Vektoren sind alle äquivalent bis auf eine globale Phase, also spielt es auch hier keine Rolle, was Phi ist. Wenn Theta jedoch strikt
zwischen null und Pi liegt, gibt es immer einen eindeutigen Wert von Phi, der funktioniert. Und übrigens wird diese mögliche
Mehrdeutigkeit im Wert von Phi für die zwei Sonderfälle vollkommen sinnvoll, wenn wir das geometrische Bild in
Kürze sehen. Jetzt berechnen wir die Dichtematrix, die einem Zustandsvektor der Form zugeordnet ist, die wir gerade
ermittelt haben. Das wird also ein reiner Zustand eines qubit sein. Dazu multiplizieren wir den Vektor
mit seiner konjugierten Transponierten wie üblich, und auf dem Bildschirm ist ein Ausdruck der Matrix, die wir durch Berechnung der
konjugierten Transponierten und Durchführung der Multiplikation erhalten. Nun, genau wie jede 2x2-
Matrix gibt es eine eindeutige Möglichkeit, diese Matrix zu erhalten, indem man eine Linearkombination der Pauli-Matrizen
einschließlich der Identitätsmatrix nimmt. Insbesondere können wir diese Matrix erhalten, indem wir die Koeffizienten der
Pauli-Matrizen wie hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wählen. Wir setzen einen Zweier in den Nenner, weil das dazu führt, dass
alles schön aufgeht. Nichts zwingt uns dazu, aber wir können es tun, und es wird hilfreich sein. Aber abgesehen von
dieser kosmetischen Wahl gibt es hier keine Freiheit – das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, diese Matrix durch eine Linearkombination von Pauli-Matrizen zu erhalten.
Das liegt daran, dass die Pauli-Matrizen einschließlich der Identitätsmatrix eine Basis für den Vektorraum aller 2x2-Matrizen bilden. Eine Möglichkeit,
die Korrektheit dieses Ausdrucks zu überprüfen, ist die Verwendung einiger grundlegender trigonometrischer Identitäten, und insbesondere wenn ich kurz aus dem Weg gehe,
haben wir hier einige Identitäten, die den Zweck erfüllen. Also, wenn du möchtest, pausiere das Video oder
mach einen Screenshot und schau, ob du den zweiten Ausdruck der Dichtematrix unten aus dem ersten herleiten kannst. Zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen: Jeder reine Zustand eines
qubit, ausgedrückt als Dichtematrix, kann als Linearkombination von Pauli-Matrizen geschrieben werden, wie auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt, für Theta zwischen 0 und Pi und Phi zwischen 0 und 2 Pi. Beachte, dass wir genau die
gleiche Mehrdeutigkeit wie zuvor haben, nämlich dass Phi irrelevant ist, wenn Theta entweder null oder Pi ist, und dieses Mal können wir das tatsächlich
klarer sehen, weil der Sinus von Theta in diesen beiden Fällen null ist, und sonst nicht. Es ist der Mühe wert, darauf hinzuweisen,
dass in dieser Formel Theta als Argument für die Sinus- und Kosinusfunktionen erscheint, anstatt Theta geteilt durch 2 wie in der ursprünglichen Quantenzustandsvektor-
Version. Das liegt daran, dass wir diese trigonometrischen Identitäten verwendet haben, von denen die ersten drei im Wesentlichen
Umformungen der sogenannten Doppelwinkelformeln, sodass der Winkel effektiv verdoppelt wird, und jetzt sind wir endlich bereit,
über die Bloch-Sphäre selbst zu sprechen. Konzentrieren wir uns auf die drei Koeffizienten des Nicht-Identitäts-Pauli-
Matrices im Zähler des Ausdrucks unserer Dichtematrix – wir ignorieren also die Zwei im
Nenner, und wir ignorieren auch die Identitätsmatrix, weil sich der Koeffizient davon nie ändert. Das liegt daran, dass
dieser Koeffizient durch die Spur der jeweiligen Matrix bestimmt wird, und Dichtematrizen haben immer die Spur
eins. Stell dir jetzt vor, wir haben drei Achsen, die mit x, y und z beschriftet sind und entsprechend der
sogenannten Rechte-Hand-Regel ausgerichtet sind, und betrachte den Punkt, dessen Koordinaten mit den drei Koeffizienten übereinstimmen. Nur um das klarzustellen:
Das ist der gewöhnliche dreidimensionale Raum, von dem wir sprechen, wo die Koordinaten immer reelle Zahlen sind. Die
x-Koordinate entspricht dem Koeffizienten der Sigma-X-Pauli-Matrix im Zähler unseres Ausdrucks, der immer eine reelle Zahl ist, weil Dichte-
matrizen hermitesch sind, und dasselbe gilt für y und z. Was wir feststellen, ist, dass dieser Punkt,
den wir erhalten, immer auf der Einheitssphäre liegt – anders gesagt, auf der Sphäre mit dem Radius
eins. Und insbesondere ist es der Punkt, den wir erhalten, wenn wir beim Punkt beginnen, wo die positive z-Achse die Sphäre schneidet,
was wir uns als Nordpol vorstellen können, dann um einen Winkel Theta in Richtung der positiven x-Achse nach unten rotieren und dann
in Richtung der positiven y-Achse – also nach Osten – um einen Winkel phi rotieren. In diesem Zusammenhang wird der Winkel Theta als
Polarwinkel bezeichnet, was leicht zu merken ist, weil er am Pol beginnt, und phi wird Azimutwinkel
genannt. Zusammen stellen diese beiden Winkel sphärische Koordinaten für die Punkte auf der Einheitssphäre dar. Und wenn du
möchtest, könntest du auch den Radius variieren lassen, um beliebige Punkte im dreidimensionalen Raum darzustellen, aber hier konzentrieren wir uns auf Punkte auf der
Einheitssphäre, wo der Radius gleich eins ist. Du kannst Theta auch als Breitengrad betrachten, außer dass wir
von 0 bis 180° vom Nordpol zum Südpol gehen, anstatt plus/minus 90° vom Äquator, und phi entspricht
dem Längengrad, wobei wir den Nullmeridian im Wesentlichen als den Meridian definieren, der die positive
x-Achse schneidet. Falls es dir wie mir geht und du Schwierigkeiten hast, auseinanderzuhalten, was Breite und was Länge ist, könnte es hilfreich sein, daran zu denken,
dass der Längengrad dem längeren Intervall entspricht – 2 pi statt
pi. Wie auch immer – der Punkt, den wir auf der Einheitssphäre aus unserem qubit-Zustandsvektor Psi erhalten, indem wir Koordinaten auf diese
Weise betrachten, ist die Bloch-Sphären-Darstellung des Quantenzustands, der Psi entspricht. Und wenn wir die gesamte
dreidimensionale Einheitssphäre auf diese Weise betrachten, erhalten wir die Bloch-Sphäre. Geometrisch ist sie nur eine Einheits-
sphäre im gewöhnlichen dreidimensionalen Raum, aber das ist tatsächlich die Geometrie der qubit-
Zustände. Es gibt hier eine perfekte Eins-zu-eins-Entsprechung: Jeder reine Zustand eines qubit entspricht einem eindeutigen Punkt auf
der Sphäre, und jeder Punkt auf der Sphäre repräsentiert einen eindeutigen qubit-Zustand bis auf eine globale Phase. Wenn wir mit
Quantenzustandsvektoren arbeiten, hat diese Entsprechung übrigens auch andere Namen – sie wird manchmal auch Poincaré-Sphäre
genannt, zum Beispiel. Aber im Kontext der Quanteninformation wird sie im Allgemeinen als Bloch-Sphäre bezeichnet. Beachte, dass wir jetzt die
Entartung beim Winkel phi recht deutlich sehen können, weil der Längengrad an Nord- und Südpol keine Bedeutung hat. Aber abgesehen
von den Polen hat jeder Punkt auf der Erde eindeutige Koordinaten in Breite und Länge, und dasselbe passiert hier. So funktioniert also
die Bloch-Sphäre im Allgemeinen. Schauen wir uns jetzt ein paar konkrete Beispiele von qubit-Zuständen an und
wo sie auf der Bloch-Sphäre liegen. Fangen wir mit der Standardbasis an – das sind die Punkte, die wir erhalten,
wenn der Polarwinkel Theta null für den Nullzustand und Pi für den Einszustand ist. Das sind die beiden Fälle, wo der
Azimutwinkel phi irrelevant ist, wie ich bereits besprochen habe. Wir können die entsprechenden Dichtematrizen auch als lineare
Kombinationen von Pauli-Matrizen ausdrücken. Auf beide Arten kommen wir zu dem Schluss, dass diese beiden Zustände dem Nordpol und dem
Südpol der Bloch-Sphäre entsprechen. Der Nullzustand ist oben und der Einszustand ist unten.
Als nächstes finden wir die Plus- und Minus-Zustände auf der Bloch-Sphäre. Wieder können wir entweder an
Quantenzustandsvektoren oder Dichtematrizen denken. Für Quantenzustandsvektoren muss der Polarwinkel Theta diesmal Pi
/ 2 sein, damit der Nulleintrag 1/√2 ist. Der Azimutwinkel phi muss null sein
für den Plus-Zustand, weil der Einseintrag beim Plus-Zustand positiv ist, und er muss Pi oder 180° für den Minus-Zustand sein,
weil dieser in dem Fall negativ ist. Diese beiden Punkte liegen also auf dem
Äquator der Bloch-Sphäre. Der Plus-Zustand ist dort, wo die positive x-Achse die Sphäre schneidet, und der Minus-Zustand liegt auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite, wo die
negative x-Achse die Sphäre schneidet. Äquivalent dazu können wir auch aus den Pauli-Matrix-Ausdrücken für die
entsprechenden Dichtematrizen sehen, dass die y- und z-Koordinaten beide null sind, während die x-Koordinaten positiv und negativ
eins sind. Ein weiteres Beispiel ist die Plus-i-Minus-i-Basis, die der Plus-Minus-Basis ähnelt, außer dass wir den
Einseintrag zusätzlich mit i, der imaginären Einheit, multiplizieren. Den Plus-i-Zustand haben wir früher in der Lektion gesehen, und der Minus-i-Zustand ist
analog definiert. Der Polarwinkel Theta ist derselbe wie bei den Plus- und Minus-Zuständen: pi/
2. Und diesmal müssen wir den Azimutwinkel phi so wählen, dass wir i und negatives i statt 1 und negatives 1 erhalten.
Pi / 2 und 3 Pi / 2 sind die richtigen Wahlen, um das zu erreichen. Wir können auch hier wieder die
Dichtematrix-Beschreibungen dieser Zustände betrachten, und die Dinge sind den beiden vorherigen Beispielen ziemlich ähnlich, außer dass diesmal die Pauli-y-Matrix an die Stelle
von z oder x tritt. Auf der Bloch-Sphäre befinden sich diese beiden Zustände also dort, wo die y-Achse
die Sphäre schneidet. Wenn wir das ein bisschen aufräumen, können wir klarer sehen, wie die sechs Zustände, die wir gerade besprochen haben,
miteinander zusammenhängen. Für ein weiteres Beispiel – oder eigentlich eine Klasse von Beispielen – betrachte die
qubit-Zustandsvektoren, die früher und in Lektion vier aufgetaucht sind, wo der Nulleintrag der Kosinus von Alpha für eine reelle Zahl Alpha ist und der Eins-
eintrag der Sinus von Alpha ist. Wir können dabei unsere Aufmerksamkeit übrigens auf Werte von Alpha zwischen null und Pi beschränken, denn jeder
andere Wert von Alpha ergibt einen Vektor, der bis auf eine globale Phase äquivalent zu einem Vektor ist, bei dem Alpha in diesem
Bereich liegt. Wenn wir die Dichtematrizen berechnen, die mit diesen Zuständen verbunden sind, ausgedrückt als lineare Kombinationen von Pauli-Matrizen,
erhalten wir den Ausdruck, der hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Diese Berechnung wird hier nicht gezeigt, aber das ist es, was du
erhalten solltest, wenn du sie durchführst. Und was wir feststellen, ist, dass diese Zustände einen sogenannten Großkreis bilden, der
durch die Pole verläuft – genauer gesagt beginnend am Nordpol, wenn Alpha null ist, den Nullmeridian hinunter, und
den Südpol zu erreichen, wenn Alpha pi über 2 ist, und dann zurück zum Nordpol auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite der Kugel, wenn Alpha von pi über 2 bis
pi reicht, und das ergibt alles Sinn, weil erstens diese reelle Vektoren sind, sodass der Imaginärteil immer null ist, und
zweitens der Winkel Alpha auf der Bloch-Kugel effektiv verdoppelt wird, und das lässt sich wiederum durch die Verwendung
der Doppelwinkelformeln erklären. Wir haben gesehen, dass die Bloch-Kugel eine sehr schöne geometrische Darstellung für die reinen Zustände eines
qubit bietet, wobei jeder Punkt auf der Kugel einem eindeutigen reinen Zustand eines qubit entspricht und umgekehrt.
Wenn wir von der Bloch-Kugel sprechen, meinen wir alle Punkte auf der Bloch-Kugel sowie die Punkte
im Inneren. Punkte im Inneren der Bloch-Kugel entsprechen ebenfalls qubit-Zuständen,
genauer gesagt Zuständen, die keine reinen Zustände sind. Das heißt, das sind qubit-Zustände, die durch Dichtematrizen dargestellt werden können, aber nicht durch qubit-Zustandsvektoren.
Ein grundlegender Aspekt der Bloch-Kugel und der Art, wie die inneren Punkte unreine Zustände darstellen, ist,
dass konvexe Kombinationen von Punkten im Inneren der Bloch-Kugel konvexen Kombinationen von Dichtematrizen entsprechen.
Intuitiv bedeutet das, dass die Geometrie auch im Inneren der Bloch-
Kugel perfekt funktioniert. Schauen wir uns ein paar Beispiele an, beginnend mit dem Mittelpunkt der Bloch-Kugel, der den
vollständig gemischten Zustand darstellt. Der vollständig gemischte Zustand entsteht durch Mittelung der Null- und Einszustände, was mit der Tatsache übereinstimmt,
dass der Mittelpunkt der Kugel genau auf halbem Weg zwischen dem Nord- und dem Südpol liegt – und tatsächlich liegt er auf halbem Weg zwischen je zwei antipodalen Punkten, wie zum Beispiel
den Plus- und Minus-Zuständen sowie den Plus-i- und Minus-i-Zuständen. Antipodalen Punkte auf der Bloch-Kugel entsprechen immer
orthogonalen reinen Zuständen. Das zeigt uns, dass wir den vollständig gemischten Zustand immer
als Durchschnitt zweier beliebiger orthogonaler reiner qubit-Zustände schreiben können. Eine andere Möglichkeit, das zu sehen, ist,
die Pauli-Matrix-Darstellung des vollständig gemischten Zustands zu betrachten. Damit das funktioniert, müssen wir
die Koeffizienten aller drei nicht-Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen auf null setzen. Der entsprechende Punkt im Inneren der
Bloch-Kugel liegt also genau im Mittelpunkt, am Ursprung. Übrigens zeigt das Nachdenken über Pauli-Matrix-Darstellungen von Dichtematrizen
ziemlich klar, dass konvexe Kombinationen von Bloch-Kugel-Punkten konvexen
Kombinationen von Dichtematrizen entsprechen. Wenn wir einen Durchschnitt oder einen gewichteten Durchschnitt von Dichtematrizen nehmen und
alles als Linearkombinationen von Pauli-Matrizen ausdrücken, mitteln wir natürlich einfach die entsprechenden Punkte, weil alles
linear in diesen drei Koeffizienten ist. Für ein weiteres Beispiel betrachten wir den Durchschnitt des Null-Zustands
und des Plus-Zustands, den wir zuvor in der Lektion gesehen haben. Wir haben die Dichtematrix-Darstellung berechnet, die auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt wird, und der Punkt liegt im Inneren der Bloch-Kugel, auf halbem Weg zwischen dem Null- und dem Plus-
Zustand. Wir haben auch gesehen, dass wir diese Dichtematrix auf eine andere Weise ausdrücken können, basierend auf ihrer Spektralzerlegung, und
das stimmt wiederum mit dem Diagramm und den vorherigen Beispielen überein. Damit ist die
Diskussion der Bloch-Kugel abgeschlossen. Oft wird gefragt, ob es eine Bloch-Kugel für Systeme mit
drei oder mehr klassischen Zuständen gibt, und die leider ernüchternde Antwort lautet: nicht wirklich. Wir können die
Quantenzustände eines Systems immer in geometrischen Begriffen ähnlich wie bei der Bloch-Kugel betrachten und erhalten einen konvexen Körper in einem reellen Vektorraum,
aber wenn wir drei oder mehr klassische Zustände haben, wird er nicht sphärisch sein. Wenn wir zum Beispiel
genau drei klassische Zustände haben, also ein Qutrit (kurz), erhalten wir einen konvexen Körper in einem achtdimensionalen
Raum, aber die Extrempunkte dieses Körpers, die den reinen Quantenzuständen eines Qutrits entsprechen, sind nur
vierdimensional. Wenn du dir vorstellen kannst, wie man eine vierdimensionale Mannigfaltigkeit in einem achtdimensionalen Raum nimmt und sie irgendwie einschweißt, um einen konvexen
Körper zu erhalten, und du das für eine hilfreiche Denkweise hältst, dann viel Erfolg damit. Es ist zwar interessant,
darüber nachzudenken, aber es ist keine Kugel – es ist komplizierter als das. Im letzten Teil der Lektion werden wir kurz besprechen,
wie Dichtematrizen für mehrere Systeme funktionieren. Dichtematrizen können Zustände mehrerer Systeme darstellen, und das
funktioniert vollständig analog zu Quantenzustandsvektoren. Insbesondere können wir, genau wie in einer vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanten-
information, mehrere Systeme zusammen betrachten, als wären sie ein einziges zusammengesetztes
System. Diesmal werden sowohl die Zeilen als auch die Spalten von Dichtematrizen, die Zustände mehrerer Systeme darstellen,
dem kartesischen Produkt der klassischen Zustandsmengen der einzelnen Systeme zugeordnet. Wir können zum Beispiel
Dichtematrix-Darstellungen der vier Bell-Zustände betrachten, die wir genau so erhalten haben wie für andere Quantenzustandsvektoren
zuvor in der Lektion, indem wir Zustandsvektoren mit ihren konjugiert transponierten multiplizieren. Die Ergebnisse sind hier auf dem
Bildschirm zu sehen. Im Wesentlichen gibt es auf konzeptueller Ebene wirklich nichts Neues, obwohl wir gleich sehen werden, dass es einige
neue Dinge gibt, die wir mit Dichtematrizen für mehrere Systeme tun können. Die Begriffe Unabhängigkeit und
Korrelationen übertragen sich von Quantenzustandsvektoren auf Dichtematrizen, und insbesondere stellen Tensorprodukte
von Dichtematrizen Unabhängigkeit zwischen Systemen dar. Wir verwenden dieselbe Terminologie, die
wir für Quantenzustandsvektoren verwendet haben. Wenn wir zum Beispiel ein System X haben, das im Zustand Rho präpariert ist, und ein System Y,
das unabhängig davon im Zustand Sigma präpariert ist, dann ist der Zustand des Paares XY zusammen durch das Tensorprodukt
von Rho und Sigma gegeben. Wir nennen das einen Produktzustand, und das verallgemeinert sich auf natürliche Weise auf mehr als zwei
Systeme. Dichtematrizen, die nicht als Produktzustände ausgedrückt werden können, stellen Korrelationen zwischen Systemen dar, und das
ist ähnlich wie bei Quantenzustandsvektoren. Aber es stellt sich heraus, dass es verschiedene Arten von Korrelationen geben kann, wenn wir Dichtematrizen verwenden – selbst für
nur zwei Systeme. Im Gegensatz dazu gibt es für Quantenzustandsvektoren wirklich nur eine Art von Korrelation, und
das ist Verschränkung. Anders ausgedrückt: Korrelation und Verschränkung sind für Quantenzustandsvektoren gleichbedeutend, aber
das gilt nicht für Dichtematrizen. Hier sind die Dinge interessanter. Zum Beispiel können wir
korrelierte klassische Zustände mit Dichtematrizen beschreiben. Hier ist ein Beispiel einer Dichtematrix, die einen klassischen zufälligen
Bit darstellt, der zwischen Alice und Bob geteilt wird. Sie haben immer denselben klassischen Zustand, Null oder Eins, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist
1/2 für jede der Möglichkeiten. Das ist kein verschränkter Zustand – Verschränkung ist nicht-klassisch –, aber
es ist ein korrelierter Zustand. Ein weiteres Beispiel ist mit dem Begriff eines Ensembles von Quantenzuständen verbunden,
das du dir als Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung über einer endlichen Menge von Quantenzuständen vorstellen kannst. Stellen wir uns insbesondere vor, dass
wir M Dichtematrizen haben, Rho null bis Rho M minus eins, die alle mögliche Zustände eines bestimmten Systems darstellen.
zusammen mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit, jede davon zu ziehen – wenn wir wollten, könnten wir den gewichteten Durchschnitt dieser Dichtematrizen
berechnen, indem wir eine konvexe Kombination davon bilden, aber das würde uns nicht verraten, welche die einzelnen Zustände waren oder was
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten waren. Was wir stattdessen tun können – und es ist manchmal sehr nützlich –, ist, eine Dichtematrix
der hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Form zu betrachten. Dies ist ein Zustand zweier Systeme, bei dem das erste System einen klassischen
Zustand für jede der Alternativen hat, und wir bilden den gewichteten Durchschnitt von M Produktzuständen, bei denen der Zustand des
ersten Systems immer klassisch ist und im Wesentlichen kennzeichnet, welchen der m Zustände wir für das zweite
System haben. Falls nicht ganz klar ist, warum wir über solche Zustände nachdenken wollen – das ist in Ordnung, es ist nur ein Beispiel für
eine Art von Korrelation, bei der das erste System immer klassisch ist und das zweite System sich in einem Quanten-
zustand befinden kann. Eine dritte Kategorie möglicherweise korrelierter Zustände ist die Menge der sogenannten separablen
Zustände. Einfach ausgedrückt sind dies konvexe Kombinationen von Produktzuständen, und sie stellen im Wesentlichen Quanten-
zustände dar, bei denen alle Korrelationen zwischen den Systemen klassische Korrelationen sind. Eine Möglichkeit, über solche
Zustände nachzudenken, ist: Wir treffen eine probabilistische Auswahl für eine Zahl K und bereiten dann unabhängig voneinander zwei
Systeme in einem Quantenzustand vor, der von dieser Wahl von K abhängen kann. Was vielleicht am interessantesten an
Zuständen dieser Form ist: So definieren wir tatsächlich Verschränkung in mathematischen Begriffen. Insbesondere ist Verschränkung
als das Fehlen von Separabilität definiert. Wenn du also eine Dichtematrix hast und es nicht möglich ist, sie in einer Form
wie dieser auszudrücken, dann ist sie per Definition verschränkt. Ich habe darauf schon in Lektion Vier hingewiesen, und hier ist es etwas
ausführlicher. Übrigens kann es sehr schwierig sein herauszufinden, ob eine gegebene Dichtematrix einen verschränkten
Zustand darstellt – selbst mit Hilfe eines Computers. Mathematisch und rechnerisch gesehen ist Verschränkung
tatsächlich ziemlich kompliziert. Ich habe zu Beginn der Lektion erwähnt, dass es etwas sehr Wichtiges gibt, das wir mit Dichtematrizen tun können:
nämlich die Zustände isolierter Teile von Systemen zu beschreiben, auch wenn sie mit anderen Systemen korreliert und möglicherweise verschränkt sind.
Der Begriff reduzierter Zustand wird in diesem Zusammenhang oft verwendet, und als einfaches Beispiel berechnen wir den reduzierten
Zustand der einzelnen qubits, die ein Ebit bilden. Um genau zu sein: Nehmen wir an, dass
Alice und Bob ein Ebit teilen – Alice hält qubit A, Bob hält qubit B, und zusammen befinden sich diese beiden qubits in einem Phi-
plus-Zustand. Die Frage, die wir beantworten werden, lautet: Was ist der Zustand von Alices qubit A in
Isolation? Natürlich könnten wir dieselbe Frage für Bobs qubit stellen, aber diese Frage lässt sich leicht beantworten, sobald wir die Antwort auf diese hier
kennen. Man könnte versucht sein zu sagen, dass wir den Zustand von Alices qubit nicht isoliert beschreiben können, weil es
mit Bobs qubit verschränkt ist, was uns irgendwie daran hindern könnte, den Zustand von A in
Isolation zu beschreiben oder auch nur daran zu denken. Aber das ist falsch. Es stimmt, dass wir den Zustand von A nicht mit einem Quanten-
zustandsvektor beschreiben können, weil er – wie wir sehen werden – nicht in einem reinen Zustand ist. Aber jedes System hat zu jedem Zeitpunkt einen Zustand, der
durch eine Dichtematrix beschrieben werden kann, egal ob es mit einem anderen System verschränkt ist oder nicht. Als Gedankenexperiment, um
uns die Antwort auf diese Frage zu verdeutlichen: Nehmen wir an, Bob beschließt, sein qubit zu nehmen und zu den Sternen zu reisen, und man hört nie wieder von ihm.
Aber stell dir vor, dass er irgendwo auf dem Weg beschließt, eine Standardbasismessung an seinem
qubit durchzuführen. Nun wissen wir, wie wir die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die beiden möglichen Ergebnisse berechnen, und wir wissen auch, welchen
Zustand A bei jedem möglichen Ergebnis haben wird. Diese Dinge sind in dieser Tabelle zusammengefasst. Insbesondere wird A mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2
im Null-Zustand hinterlassen, und mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 wird A im Eins-Zustand hinterlassen. Und so – wie weiter oben in
der Lektion besprochen – hinterlässt dies A im vollständig gemischten Zustand, und das ist somit die Antwort
auf unsere Frage. Nun könntest du einwenden und sagen, dass dies davon abhängt, dass
Bob beschlossen hat, sein qubit zu messen, und dass die Annahme, dass er dies tut, Teil der Geschichte ist, die uns zu dieser Antwort geführt hat. Aber
wenn Bob Lichtjahre entfernt ist, wenn er misst, kann nichts, was er tut, irgendwelchen Einfluss auf irgendein
Experiment haben, das Alice an ihrem qubit durchführen könnte – sonst hätten wir Überlichtgeschwindigkeits-
kommunikation. Also befindet sich Alices qubit im vollständig gemischten Zustand, unabhängig davon, ob Bob
misst oder nicht. Ich sollte an dieser Stelle klarstellen, dass der Begriff des reduzierten Zustands und die Art, wie er definiert wird, keine wirkliche Abhängigkeit von der Relativitätstheorie hat
oder von der Unmöglichkeit der Überlichtgeschwindigkeitskommunikation. Das ist nur eine Möglichkeit, es hoffentlich intuitiv zu erklären.
In der Realität gibt es eine mathematische Definition, die wir in wenigen Momenten in einem allgemeineren Kontext sehen werden. Sie ist konsistent mit dieser Antwort
und zufälligerweise auch mit der Unmöglichkeit der Überlichtgeschwindigkeitskommunikation. Und es gibt auch keine andere
Definition, die mit der Quanteninformation, wie wir sie kennen, konsistent sein könnte. Betrachten wir nun reduzierte Zustände in größerer
Allgemeinheit. Nehmen wir an, wir haben ein Paar von Systemen A und B – nicht notwendigerweise qubits –, die sich zusammen in einem reinen Zustand befinden,
dargestellt durch einen Quantenzustandsvektor s. Wieder konzentrieren wir uns auf den reduzierten Zustand des Systems A, und dazu
wird es hilfreich sein, über die klassischen Zustände des Systems B nachzudenken. Sei Gamma also diese Menge von
klassischen Zuständen von B, wie wir es zuvor in Lektion zwei der Reihe besprochen haben.
Es gibt eine eindeutige Sammlung von Vektoren f_b für jedes B in Gamma, für die der auf dem Bildschirm gezeigte Ausdruck von s
korrekt ist. Und es gibt insbesondere eine einfache Formel für diese Vektoren: Wir multiplizieren den Vektor s einfach mit dem
Tensorprodukt der Identitätsmatrix entsprechend System A mit dem Bra B für das jeweilige B, für das wir uns
interessieren. Was wir hier tun, ist im Grunde, uns darauf vorzubereiten zu berechnen, was passieren würde, wenn wir eine
Standardbasismessung an B durchführen würden. Und wieder wurde dies in Lektion zwei der
Reihe behandelt. Wenn wir also eine Standardbasismessung an B durchführen würden, würde jedes mögliche Ergebnis mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich dem
euklidischen Normbetrag-Quadrat des entsprechenden Vektors Phi_b auftreten. Und unter der Bedingung, dass wir ein
bestimmtes Ergebnis B erhalten, normieren wir den Vektor Phi_b, um den resultierenden Zustand von
A zu bestimmen. Mit derselben Überlegung wie im Ebit-Beispiel von vorhin erhalten wir den auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigten Ausdruck für den reduzierten Zustand von A als Dichtematrix. Und übrigens: Das Normbetrag-Quadrat im Nenner kommt daher, dass
wir den normierten Vektor mit seiner konjugierten Transponierten multiplizieren, sodass wir die euklidische Norm zweimal im
Nenner aufnehmen. Die euklidischen Normbetrag-Quadrate heben sich auf, und wir erhalten einen ziemlich einfachen
Ausdruck, und wenn wir tatsächlich unsere Formel für 5B einsetzen, die für jedes B gilt, erhalten wir eine Formel für den reduzierten
Zustand des Systems a in Form der Dichtematrix-Beschreibung des reinen Zustands, mit dem wir begonnen haben, nämlich csai
brasai – das ist also unsere Formel für den reduzierten Zustand des Systems a, angenommen, das zusammengesetzte System AB begann in
dem reinen Zustand sigh. Wir können die Formel aber auch allgemeiner verwenden – nehmen wir insbesondere an,
dass der Zustand von ab durch eine Dichtematrix row gegeben ist, die für einen bestimmten Quantenzustand die Form K SI brai annehmen könnte
Vektor s, aber nicht notwendigerweise. Es folgt im Wesentlichen durch Linearität, dass der reduzierte Zustand von a
durch dieselbe Formel bestimmt wird, die wir für reine Zustände hatten, außer dass wir stattdessen die Dichtematrix row einsetzen, welche wir
möchten. Als Kurznotation ist es ziemlich üblich, dass wir diesen reduzierten Zustand mit dem Namen bezeichnen, den wir für die
Dichtematrix row verwenden, aber mit einem Subskript, das das System angibt, auf das wir uns konzentrieren – also row mit einem
Subskript a bedeutet den reduzierten Zustand von a, wenn sich das zusammengesetzte System im Zustand row befindet. Superskripte werden manchmal auch
anstelle von Subskripten verwendet – das ist im Wesentlichen nur eine persönliche Präferenz und bedeutet dasselbe.
Wir haben uns der Einfachheit halber auf System a konzentriert, können aber auch den reduzierten Zustand des Systems B
analog bestimmen, wobei die Formel auf natürliche Weise angepasst wird. Alles ist hier symmetrisch – wir
tauschen im Wesentlichen nur die Rollen von A und B, und insbesondere läuft die Summe diesmal über die klassischen Zustände von a
statt von b. In der Formel auf dem Bildschirm gehen wir davon aus, dass die klassische Zustandsmenge von a
Sigma heißt. All das lässt sich auf ziemlich unkomplizierte Weise auf drei oder mehr Systeme verallgemeinern – wenn wir beispielsweise drei
Systeme a, b und c haben, die sich gemeinsam in dem durch die Dichtematrix row beschriebenen Zustand befinden, können wir den
reduzierten Zustand des Paares a gemeinsam durch die hier gezeigte Formel erhalten, sowie den Zustand des dritten Systems allein,
was die zweite Formel ist. Man kann andere Kombinationen betrachten und dies auf beliebig viele Systeme verallgemeinern. Die Summen werden immer über
die klassischen Zustandsmengen der Systeme gebildet, die ignoriert werden, und das Muster ist immer dasselbe, wobei die Dichtematrix,
mit der wir begonnen haben, zwischen dem Tensorprodukt der Einheitsmatrix und Bras und Kets, die den Standardbasisvektoren entsprechen, eingebettet wird.
Zum Abschluss der Lektion möchte ich noch ein wenig mehr zu den Definitionen sagen, die wir gerade behandelt haben. Die Operation auf Dichte-
matrizen, die reduzierte Zustände beschreibt, hat einen Namen: Sie heißt partielle Spur. Für zwei Systeme A und B ist die
partielle Spur über B und die partielle Spur über a so definiert, wie hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Das sind genau dieselben
Formeln, die wir vor wenigen Momenten gesehen haben, und jetzt denken wir nur über sie als Funktionen von row nach und geben ihnen
Namen. Die Namen sehen aus wie die Spur, außer dass es ein Subskript gibt, das uns sagt, welches System entfernt wird –
oder mit anderen Worten, welches System dasjenige ist, dessen klassische Zustandsmenge wir summieren und das zwischen einem Bra und einem
Ket eingebettet wird. Wenn wir die partielle Spur unseres B nehmen, die beispielsweise durch die erste Formel beschrieben wird, sagen wir manchmal,
dass b herausgespurt wird – und entsprechend für a. Intuitiv gesprochen bedeutet ein System herausspuren,
dass wir es wegwerfen oder einfach ignorieren. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, die partielle
Spur zu definieren, und eine andere äquivalente Möglichkeit besteht darin zu sagen, dass diese Abbildungen die eindeutigen linearen Abbildungen sind, die die
hier auf der rechten Seite gezeigten Formeln erfüllen. Wenn wir insbesondere ein Tensorprodukt zweier Matrizen M und N haben, sagen wir,
und wir führen die partielle Spur über das erste System aus, dann erhalten wir die Spur der ersten Matrix M multipliziert mit
der zweiten Matrix. Die Bedingung ist symmetrisch, wenn wir über das zweite System spuren. Nicht jede Matrix, für die wir
die partielle Spur berechnen würden, ist ein Tensorprodukt wie dieses, aber jede Matrix lässt sich als Linearkombination von
Tensorprodukten ausdrücken, und wir können die partielle Spur aus diesen Bedingungen zusammen mit der Tatsache bestimmen, dass diese Funktionen linear sind.
Das erklärt, warum es partielle Spur heißt. Diese äquivalente Definition kann
sehr hilfreich sein, da wir sie oft anstelle der ursprünglichen Formel verwenden können. Hier ist ein Beispiel, das
das veranschaulicht: Angenommen, wir haben ein Paar von cubits a in dem Zustand, dessen Dichtematrix hier auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Dies ist zufällig ein Beispiel für einen korrelierten Zustand, bei dem a entweder im Nullzustand oder im Einzustand ist, jeweils
mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2. Wir können also a als klassisch betrachten. Wenn a im Nullzustand ist, dann ist es
auch B, und wenn a im Einzustand ist, dann ist B im Plus-Zustand. Wenn wir wissen wollen, was der reduzierte Zustand von a ist,
spuren wir B heraus. Wenn wir die zweite Formel aus der äquivalenten Definition zusammen mit Linearität verwenden, können wir
das ziemlich einfach berechnen. Insbesondere ist die Spur von k0 bra 0 eins, ebenso wie die Spur von K plus bra
plus. Diese Tensorfaktoren verschwinden also, und wir bleiben mit dem vollständig gemischten Zustand. Auf ähnliche Weise können wir den
reduzierten Zustand von B berechnen, indem wir diesmal a herausspuren. Es ist der erste Tensorfaktor, über den wir die Spur bilden, also
verwenden wir die erste Formel aus der äquivalenten Definition und erhalten 1/2 * ket 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 * ket
plus bra plus – oder mit anderen Worten dieselbe Dichtematrix, die bereits einige Male aufgetaucht ist. Man würde genau dieselben
Ergebnisse erhalten, wenn man die Formeln aus der ersten Definition verwendet, aber das ist ein viel einfacherer Weg. All das verallgemeinert sich auf drei oder mehr
Systeme, aber für dieses Video höre ich hier auf und überlasse das dir zum selbstständigen Nachdenken. Damit ist diese Lektion abgeschlossen, in der
wir Dichtematrizen eingeführt und die Grundlagen ihrer Funktionsweise beschrieben haben. Wir haben auch die Bloch-Sphäre besprochen,
sowie verschiedene Arten von Korrelationen und den Begriff des reduzierten Zustands eines Systems. Ich hoffe, du bist dabei, wenn
wir zur nächsten Lektion kommen, die über Kanäle handelt – lineare Abbildungen von Dichtematrizen zu Dichtematrizen, die
Operationen auf Systemen beschreiben. Auf Wiedersehen bis
dann